[Musik]
dieser film handelt von max und seinen
eltern prägt und stefan vogel eigentlich
hätte die geschichte dieser jungen
familie erst im januar vor einem jahr
beginnen sollen dann nämlich war der
geburtstermin von max durch tragische
umstände kam der kleine bub drei monate
zu früh auf die welt
[Musik]
in der 26
das ist ziemlich heftig sie will der
technik um mega einheit kam mir diese
chance kommt klingt ja schon
angst
[Musik]
max ist nicht das einzige kind von
brigit und stefan vogel bringt vogel war
schwanger mit zwillingen bei einer
routineuntersuchung in der 25
schwangerschaftswoche merkte man dass
eines der babys viel zu klein war als
seine herztöne immer schlechter wurden
holten die ärzte der frauenklinik basel
die zwillinge notfallmässig per
kaiserschnitt auf die welt das war am 27
oktober 2011
im mittelpunkt standen
max überlebt
mit einem gewicht von knapp einem kilo
ist er doppelt so schwer wie seine
verstorbene schwester doch die ersten
wochen sind kritisch auf der
neonatologie der frauenklinik kämpft ein
team aus ärzten und pflegern um sein
leben es gibt komplikationen mit der
lunge er muss künstlich beatmet werden
und es droht die gefahr einer hirn
blutung
nach fünf wochen hat max die kritischste
phase überstanden jeden tag während
mehrerer stunden stehen die eltern an
seinem bettchen oft hilflos weil sie
nichts für ihn tun können
[Musik]
ein inniger moment für eltern und kind
ist deshalb das känguru
ich bin
das bestätigt
noch laufen
[Musik]
die ein zwei stunden auf der nackten
brust der eltern sind wichtig für die
entwicklung der frühchen
ist ein schwieriges thema aber nicht
einmal selber dass man kennt sich man
das metall haben und ist
voller angst das service und kassierte
seine zweite wenn man macht einfach
mitnimmt
und bank natürlich einen und in der
zwischenzeit max fünf heimspiele jetzt
schon auf gewalt und macht sich gut
macht fortschritte
letzten zwei wochen nicht zu und sind
immer positiven
fortschritte gemacht wenn man alle daten
unbedingt angst dass man es karten
eigentlich liebe nicht weghören machen
in der nacht mit ihm verbracht oder
gerade irgendwie unruhigere so und dass
sie zwei wochen sieben gesehen dass gott
ihn wirklich stabil konstant besser
zu gesicht und julian ganze bezirk
unternimmt
es ist
max davon ein neues mädchen er ist nun
so stabil dass er den brutkasten nicht
mehr braucht
es sind diese kleinen aber stetigen
entwicklungsschritte die den eltern mut
machen und ihnen eine perspektive geben
die hoffnung dass sie ihren sohn gesund
nach hause nehmen dürfen
az wer wird entwickelt und sie sehr
fröhlich
funktioniert man einfach mal macht ihr
einfach das ziel das ist ein kind gut
gott dass es gott die kraft aufbringen
was braucht das kind hatte rosi
aufführen und rosé oder lukas zu stecken
und
konnte mit den anträgen etwas auf
das man das wichtigste habt ihr wirklich
auf das begrenzt dass die triebe ganz
doofe
max stephan
spital und ganz ganz wenig kontakt zu
der angst der familienmitglieder aber
ganz wenig kontakt bis max nach hause
darf geht es noch einige wochen er muss
noch viel an größe und gewicht aufholen
und vor allem ohne atemhilfe atmen
können
heute ist nur sein vater zu besuch die
mutter hat die grippe die eltern werden
auf der neonatologie früh in die pflege
der kinder mit einbezogen
bei milch geben ist der vater schon
routiniert über eine magensonde erhält
das frühchen abgepumpte muttermilch
[Musik]
nun wagt sich der vater das erste mal
entwickeln
der veränderung zu haben ja sehr
herzlich mit der mordserie
diese
die pflegenden und ärzte sind wichtige
bezugspersonen für die eltern sie machen
ihnen immer wieder mut
wir brauchen einfach noch geduld
[Musik]
fünf monate später wir besuchen die
familie an einem sommertag zu hause in
elz bei basel im januar drei monate nach
der geburt konnten die eltern maxeiner
bruchgefahr den erwarteten geburtstermin
mit nach hause nehmen die eltern
erzählen dass die letzten wochen trotz
der großen freude nicht einfach waren
die angst max könnte plötzlich aufhören
zu atmen war immer da
tatsächlich hatte er bei einer
augenuntersuchung einen atemaussetzer
doch max hat sich prächtig entwickelt
das einst winzige menschlein ist kaum
wiederzuerkennen
[Musik]
die positive entwicklung von max macht
den eltern mut sie können die schwierige
zeit etwas hinter sich lassen
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
dennoch spannten sie immer wieder
zwischen unbeschwertheit und angst
[Musik]
macht
das heißt nicht dass luft im kongo
loacker will halt irgendeinem strich das
hab ich nämlich nun für die karten
gottesstaat disney kritisch
ein paar wochen später an einem
sonntagnachmittag im basler zolli die
eltern wollen max das neue affengehege
zeigen
[Musik]
wachstation
regiert und stefan vogel sind fröhliche
und gesellige menschen die das leben
genießen trotz oder vielleicht gerade
wegen der vielen schicksalsschläge die
beide schon erlebt haben schwere
krankheiten und der verlust von lieben
menschen
das was sie mit ihren zwillingen erlebt
haben sagen sie das sei nochmals eine
andere dimension
die glücklichen momente mit max geben
ihnen die kraft und zuversicht das ganze
zu bearbeiten
es sind aber auch gerade diese momente
in denen seine schwester fehlt
[Musik]
präsent
und max geburtstag die eltern wollen ihn
feiern gleichzeitig haben sie gemischte
gefühle was diesen tag angeht denn es
ist auch der todestag von anna
[Musik]
stefan vogel war bei der geburt seiner
kinder nicht dabei der bls
lokomotivführer geht in seiner freizeit
oft in die berge
eigentlich hatte er damals eine
einwöchige bergtour geplant entschied
sich dann aber für eine tagestour weil
seine frau bereits im spital war
mit einer notfallmässigen geburt
rechnete niemand
als der anruf kam machte sich stefan
vogel so schnell wie möglich auf den weg
nach basel
im zug erfuhr er dann von den
dramatischen ereignissen
also ich aus dem zoo gefahren durch mini
froh dass es da noch nicht geschafft hat
das ist einfach der gedanke so schnell
wie möglich zu ihr ins spital
und
thq
hat
nationaltrainer sind flossen
und
donner ist teil
unserer geschichte und
kölner
gelacht wie sie überspringt wie sie groß
wird
das sagt ein vater der früher nie kinder
haben wollte und dann als er sich darauf
einstellte und sich freute so vom
schicksal getroffen wurde
es ist der 28
oktober gestern feierte die familie den
ersten geburtstag von max und sie
trauerte um ihre tochter die an diesem
tag starb sie feierten im engsten
freundes und familienkreis und waren
froh um etwas ablenkung
oder
euro mit der bedingung
dass
ich nicht nur
blumen und kerzen für anna die eltern
wollten sie in der nähe haben und haben
ihre urne bei sich im garten begraben wo
möchten sie für sich behalten
mal weniger das ist eben das so so so
waren sie interessant ist auch hier und
jetzt dass sie den bau
der woche zwei an ist für realisieren
zum grab
ein früher abend anfang januar kredit
vogel kommt mit max ins kinderspital
basel
diesmal nicht für eine untersuchung
sondern zum austausch mit anderen eltern
von zu früh geborenen kindern die
elterngruppe trifft sich einmal im monat
mit dabei sind auch immer pflegende die
die kinder auf der neonatologie betreut
haben
sind alles ehemalige patientin von uns
eben alle frühgeborene die wirklich
lange lange zeit in spittal verbrachten
mit ganz eng verknüpft ware und für dies
zu abrupt dieser diese trennung
eigentlich von spittal zum 3 1 ein
bisschen froh wenn sie die möglichkeit
hätten zum antreffen keine lerne zum
leben mit einer austausch möglich machen
und sich da wirklich austauschen
[Musik]
das buch
ist können
das ist und ich finde ich habe ich mich
sehr
auf die station
[Musik]
vorgesehen
ein paar wochen später die einjahres
kontrolle im kinderspital steht bevor
heute zeigt sich wie gut sich max in den
letzten monaten entwickelt hat
das so schwierig zu beurteilen
abschätzen das ist eigentlich mehr oder
weniger alles kritisch zum heutigen
zeitpunkt was das heißt man biete den
letzten tag aber demnächst der molen
schwierigkeiten oder besonders wachhund
und dänische sich nach dieser so freut
wie eine rhetorisch und ich glaube man
hätte nichts anders kann sie schwierig
ich danke mir bezahlt die situation ist
kam es gar nicht abschätzen
max kann zwar im oktober auf die welt
für die ärzte aber gilt sein eigentlich
berechnete geburtstermin im januar
gemäss diesem wäre max jetzt zwölf
monate alt und
an diesem alter misst die ärztin in
einer entwicklungs neurologischen
untersuchung seinen entwicklungsstand
[Musik]
wie ist sein soziales verhalten wie ist
seine sprache und wie bewegt er sich
die ärztin misst max anhand von
normwerten und kann so seine entwicklung
beurteilen falls nötig kann sie
unterstützende therapien einleiten
bei zu früh geborenen kindern werden
diese tests in regelmäßigen jahres
abständen bis ins schulalter
durchgeführt dann erst zeigt sich um ein
kind zum beispiel lernschwierigkeiten
hat eine mögliche spätfolge der viel zu
frühen geburt
bei max scheint im moment alles in
ordnung zu sein
[Musik]
völlig verlaufe extrem
ist ja alles gut
nachdem jahren mit dem marx nach dem
motto hätte lassen
für norisring
mirlach jetzt gerade will ich heute
bauwerk seit es wäre schön ein normales
kind aber ganz ehrlich
das ist training geht es halt einfach da
und das der technische fortschritt hat
und so endet diese geschichte mit einem
hoffnungsvollen ausgang als die meisten
anfangs zu hoffen wagten so wie sich
maxi moment entwickelt stehen die
chancen für ein leben ohne folgen durch
die frühgeburt gut
[Musik]